[Music]
hello i'm dr peter cerumen and i'm a
world famous erologist think about what
your ears do for you every day they let
you hear things they show off your
jewelry they even hold up your
sunglasses
unfortunately until now science has
provided no way for us to thank our ears
until now because now there's the ralph
report the ralph report is a daily
podcast that will let your ears know how
much you love them monday through friday
they'll feel appreciated as they get to
listen to showbiz news crazy funny weird
news celebrity interviews sex stories
sports stories music movie reviews and
much much more i gotta tell you this
ralph garman guy is nuts
[Applause]
and the unbelievable part is the ralph
report cost you just three dollars a
month that's right three dollars a month
you can get the ralph report monday
through friday for a whole month for
just three dollars do you know what you
usually get for three dollars
crap like this the funny old nose and
glasses bit not even a whole gallon of
gasoline for three dollars you get a
couple cheap disposable lighters
oh [ __ ] is this real gasoline
for just 15 cents a day you could feed
your starving ears at the ralph
report.com
it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hollywood babylon
with your hosts kevin smith and ralph
garvin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is saturday night in burbank man
[Applause]
so let us battle the [ __ ] out i'm kevin
smith i'm ralph garvey
uh welcome everybody uh welcome i just
want to let you know in advance
i i am covet-free
yeah
that's what they all say yes
i got me some uh covered uh i was just
tested for syphilis don't worry about it
i don't need a condom
um it is uh it was not harrowing uh
thanks to science and vaccines there was
one day where i felt all like [ __ ] up
and very fatigued just like tired and
[ __ ] but then the rest of the time even
though i was testing positive like i
just felt [ __ ] normal so it's it's
out of my system and whatnot people have
asked me like what happened how bad was
it i'm telling you what i had was kind
of mild people say like did you lose
your sense of taste and i'm like well
the internet told me i did that with
masters of the universe
which by the way is [ __ ] coming back
now if you remember from uh the first
epic season uh
the guy sitting to my left uh played a
beloved character named fisto yes
um fisto of course if you watch the show
met with uh some uh yeah spoilers
things didn't go well for physics yeah
but a dire consequence the ralph is
coming back as fisto's cousin power
bottom yeah
do the voice
[Applause]
[Laughter]
my first line
make it progress progressively easier is
this holy [ __ ] can i [ __ ] let me
share something with you this is nuts
i'm not bragging about like i live in a
nice neighborhood but you know where i
live you do and you do live in a nice
stream and to be fair you walk down like
two blocks and it's hollywood boulevard
yes but like we love up in the hills
above hollywood boulevard behind the
fence there's a gate there's some
snipers
you can literally walk up to my house
and people do there's a guy the other
day [ __ ] like i heard knocking on my
front door which never happens and [ __ ]
and i i didn't get up from my desk i
took the camera looked at the [ __ ]
camera monitor and there was a person
just standing at the door it's so like
[ __ ]
strange in our in our world like
nobody's ever [ __ ] around it's like
dead up there so so i went out on the
porch i was like what's up and he was
like hey man i said hey he's like a huge
fan
and i was like right on thank you are
you a fan of the police
because you're about to meet them
he's like oh god yeah every little thing
you do
different feelings not those guys
although you will get stumped
um but uh the uh they're
you know
i'm trying to i don't want to leave
everyone out but you know the house
that's like not right across the street
from me but across the street that's up
on an elevated hill yes so i live like
right on the street there is no [ __ ]
gates and guards and [ __ ] lawn or
anything like that you can literally
walk up to my [ __ ] door that's why
affleck sold me that house
like was like i got to get out of here i
was like why he's like i walk in my
front door they're like
who you in there with the backpack like
photographers and [ __ ] so he's like i
need something with a driveway and i was
like [ __ ] i don't and so i bought his
house
and it's worked out relatively well i've
been there for 20 years he lived in it
for six months i've lived lived in it
for 20 years we still call it affleck's
house
that's [ __ ] brand right there it's
all about billing in this town totally
all right so across the street from me
there's a house where a sweet little
family lives with a bunch of kids but
three three daughters i like
jennifer always makes fun of me because
she's like i'll give you a million
dollars if you could tell me one of
their names
and i'm like
palermo she's like no not even [ __ ]
close
so
the house that's behind them which is
like if you're going up the hill it's
the next driveway so there's a house
that's over them
that kind of looks at our house so much
so that like the length of time i've
been living in this house the that house
on the hill is the house that makes me
close the curtains when i have sex
because i'm like they have the perfect
[ __ ] vantage view
to see what's going on here so it's you
know
old style it always i always assumed to
have like a fantastic view of the city
behind it because it's very high up
but you know very like cinderblocky and
square
quiet people moved out of it recently
there was a for sale sign and then uh uh
you know [ __ ] sale pending or
whatever the [ __ ]
so we were curious the gate had been
closed for a long time
[ __ ] another day dude six lapd cop cars
roll the [ __ ] up [ __ ] everyone rolls
out with guns this [ __ ] helicopter
over the [ __ ] house wow and a dude
comes out with a [ __ ] sniper rifle
jesus and they're like get out of the
[ __ ] house right now exit the house
we are coming in
and like we were like what is it
squatters you know and that's what i
said i was like because we once had
squatters lived next to us like there
was a house that was for sale and one
day people moved in and the guy was like
hey man and i was like hi how are you
and he goes i'm uh who did he say he was
she goes i'm shook knight's son
and like how do you check that but it's
so i was like hey how are you
how's dad you know
and uh he was like he's good we're
living here now i was like ah good luck
chip night son and so
they were our neighbors for like two
years and then one day somebody came up
to our door knocked down the door and it
was a food delivery guy and he was like
who lives there and i was like oh i
should not suck he's like well they just
[ __ ] uh i brought food to them they
took it over the gate and they said they
were going in to get money and they went
in and they don't come out now and i was
like oh that's [ __ ] up and uh he was
like what do i do i was like i have no
idea my name is paul this is dwayne
y'all
call shook i guess yeah yeah truly i'm
like i'm not the i'm not the [ __ ]
endgame here i'm the guy in law and
order that you meet on the way to the
guy to the guy to the guy
so you know suddenly we were like what's
going on next door and then it turned
out that they were squatters they had
just like kind of jumped the fence broke
the locks and then made the house theirs
and it was a rare situation where the
guy that who owned the house went
bankrupt and abandoned it and the bank
was like oh no that's your house he was
like [ __ ] you it's your house and so
nobody was claiming it and so suge
knight's son was like it's my house
and it was like i remember at the time
being fascinated by this and jason muse
didn't have his own house yet and i was
like dude stop living in apartments
squat [ __ ] that's the way to go
like these cops can't get them out like
there's [ __ ] squatters rights and
[ __ ] like that so they eventually did
the bank eventually claimed that house
and so they were able to get the
squatters out so with all that was going
on was the last time i saw police in my
neighborhood except the time that they
came to our house yeah so
i'm looking at this and i'm like must be
squatters and [ __ ] jennifer's like
why would they have a helicopter for
squatters
and i was like what else could it be
it's a [ __ ] meth laugh dude
it was a [ __ ] meth lab across the
street from our house i'm driving all
the way down to [ __ ] downtown to get
my mouth
across the street
a [ __ ] breaking
i was like why didn't you let me know
i'm great at branding
the only reason they found out was i
guess there was a reportage of high
usage of gas
and so when the police showed up and
they were like get the [ __ ] out they
have two dogs on the property it was a
full out [ __ ] criminal empire
literally across the street from my
house and i'm like they might be looking
at me [ __ ] they had no interest
they were making money right yeah they
were busy but
we were told that like you know
there was uh the cops all left at a
certain point like if i get this one on
for a while like a siege and then i
guess they got the mountain [ __ ] found
out later on three people were arrested
went to jail
but at one point
there was this person like the cops were
all gone and also we were
breaking glass we looked across on the
hill there was a dude with a [ __ ]
sledgehammer busting every [ __ ]
window and breaking the doors and [ __ ]
and we were like what the [ __ ] is this
now like what turn of the [ __ ] script
is happening here turns out is the guy
who bought the property who was meant to
like level the houses and put a big new
house there and stuff just hadn't gotten
around to it yet it must be nice to be
rich
um
he was breaking the windows
because the gas had filled up the place
and they ran the risk of like
and if it exploded it was going to take
out the house our house the neighborhood
the homeland and plus like the
three kids across the street whose names
i don't [ __ ] know they would have
went right away yeah
we had no idea how close we were dude
but you would have never known there was
no i was i never woke up in the morning
i was like it smells like meth like
nothing like that never saw the only
thing if they were making hummus you'd
know oh [ __ ] yeah
i'd be over there showing them how to do
it yeah it's a hummus lab
yeah i could judge you about that [ __ ]
and be like come here let me show you
how to [ __ ] do that
they're like are you israeli i was like
no man i'm just a big [ __ ] fan yeah
i know what to do with the chicken
[Laughter]
um [ __ ] meth lab bro
what are we doing
so the guy came to your door
guy's knocking on the door you looked in
the camera big fan hey big fan i took
around wait we closed that that's it
that was all that happened yeah i
remember i talked to him and he was a
big fan of yeah that was all that was he
just he just went away he just walked
away yeah he i guess he was there for
and he [ __ ] wrong house on the way
down he was like you know what i'm
emboldened enough to stop and say hi to
one of my favorite directors i've got
the meth crowd locked up yeah i know
they're big fans oh i thought there was
a
resolution of that i did i my bad
it's so weird though i like give you a
thrilling story it was great flap across
the street you're like what happens with
the rando yeah i thought it was it was
going to be circular and then come back
to and that guy
was [ __ ] yes ezra miller
[Applause]
just thought
what do i know
uh ezra miller's at the door don't
[ __ ] open that
he will beat you they will beat you up
and take your passport give it up for
ralph
i can learn what i'm saying i can learn
not as woke as kevin but i'm getting
there
according to the interwebs you went you
[ __ ] doubled down so fast man you
were so scared you were like
hey you come to cancel cops empty
how are they [ __ ] like
i'm sorry
how did they and i'm in this case i mean
warner brothers how do they [ __ ] move
forward with that movie with all all
that's going on
um
yeah money this gentleman said and i
think that's the answer what what would
it cost to redo it i mean you're kind of
screwed at this point i mean
you're in how are you how do you do how
do you do press no no
like let's talk about the flash no i got
other questions
i'm sorry ezra there's no more press
they decided to close up shop you don't
need to do anything thanks just stay
there in hawaii and scare people
no i wouldn't i wouldn't let them do
press if i was warner brothers i would
that would keep them away from the press
right now warner brothers warner
brothers is like why didn't we cast
john cena as the flag right
have you seen this [ __ ] video it's
heart
breaking but also ultimately inspiring
there's a video that's up right now of
uh the story is this there's a mom and
she's uh in ukraine and marvels at how
you say it
and she's trying to get her non-verbal
down syndrome childbirth
on the spectrum or spectrum as well but
he's severely impaired very impaired and
like tough enough to be like we gotta
run because there's a [ __ ] war on our
heels but
tougher to explain it to
he couldn't understand why they had to
leave their home so the mom told the
kid that like
where we're going at the end of this
john cena is going to be waiting for us
yes we're leaving to go meet john cena
and so she lied she lied to the kid yeah
but [ __ ] the way that parents are like
santa and [ __ ] like that a good lie
don't [ __ ] ruin it i'm just saying oh
my god i was about to cry and you're
like she lied i'm just
i'm doing whatever i can to keep that's
all happening
um they uh
they got to amsterdam yes so they made
it which is like should be
enough like that's not where john cena
lives by the way
i just want to let that kid know mom
lied yes
good point yes um
john john cena hears about it he's an
hour away from amsterdam shooting
something shooting something and so he's
like oh my god we have to go i'm going
and he [ __ ] goes and there's this
video of him
with the kid and he's showing up and
like the f as far as that kid knows like
his mother didn't lie [ __ ] you
because
no john cena made her lie real
yes yes so i want the video of mom
blowing john cena
as a thank you for making her not lie to
her impaired child that's the video i
want to see
because that's the real favor that needs
to be transpired
there is no heat they for what you just
said
we're now married to that and
all the podcast headlines tomorrow
please let it be so
garmin attacks ukrainian woman
maybe spotify all by us he's
no john cena him
oh my god it was so [ __ ] beautiful
man i and i don't care i know some
people were like
[ __ ] the publicity stunt i don't give
a [ __ ] like
all good came from it who cares and also
like that that yeah exactly like [ __ ]
could you imagine
being able to
maintain
that delicate [ __ ] connection with
somebody who's not communicative in the
traditional way yeah and not have them
feel like betrayed like where the [ __ ]
is john cena like mom said john cena was
there
[ __ ] john cena was there
like
my mom's coming out tomorrow for a week
and a half for the first time in a
couple of years and [ __ ]
if she don't bring john cena with us
no it's not hell she could get back on
that [ __ ] night and go to orlando
you should promise mom when you get up
the plane there will be
meth why she came that's right she was
like i'm coming to see you tiger but i
know there's a [ __ ] hot meth lab
across the street into the lab
how do you do
everybody for coming out here tonight
filling up flappers we appreciate it
it's been a minute since we've done this
i can't wait to start tonight's show
claire
you're awake
okay just to make sure
claire tweeted out before we started the
show that she had been up for 27 hours
and she was coming right from the
airport to the comedy club
thank you for making that trip
then she also said you better have a
rowdy show and keep me awake
i don't need that kind of [ __ ]
pressure in my life
so i said i would just scream her name
periodically to keep her awake and it's
the best that i could do so there we go
if you really like her you'll do that
for the rest of the night and [ __ ] even
during sex just be like class
depending on how things go maybe i will
be screaming that later tonight let me
tell you something man i'm so [ __ ]
like i'm covered free right now and they
tell me i'll be covered free for a
couple months yeah so i'm feeling real
risky and chancy and [ __ ] i'm looking
door knobs
just going nuts you and me could totally
have unprotected sex
cause i can't catch nothing right now i
think you're i think you're
overestimating your immunity i don't
know pretty sure i'm invincible um i
read a tweet too before uh we went and
uh this was from uh jay martinez you
hear
over here there she is
i can't wait me and my hubby are
bringing our son to celebrate his 21st
birthday wow
how sweet of a mom are you if you would
have also delivered john
cena you only gave your kid us and he's
like what are we doing here yeah if this
is adulthood [ __ ] it i'm going back
[Music]
what's your son's name
wren
hey ren happy birthday pal
happy birthday ran
[Music]
21 jesus
do you remember it nope
100 years ago
things i would do right now if i was 21
years old i could take over the [ __ ]
world if i had the knowledge in my head
and the body of a 21 year old
my my question is if you're willing to
bring the kid out
first 21st birthday to this how far are
you willing to keep going what does that
mean
well if you're going to treat him what
are you willing to do yeah
to get al capone what are you willing to
do
how far are you willing to go with your
child like is there an after party
like what do you guys do after this like
you're an adult now you shake hands and
go to your rooms and [ __ ] or you're like
[ __ ] it let's let's do some rails and
[ __ ] get out there man
let's [ __ ] experience los angeles
or burbank you know either way
this is chuck e cheese down the street
i believe they're closed [ __ ] nuts if
you were high and [ __ ] i know where you
can get some real cheap maps
come to my house
besides claire and ren there's also
folks who've come out tonight from
particularly long distances celebrating
special occasions and we would like to
talk to them in a segment we call the
shout outs gabby
it's a shout out
we're kevin around so get your [ __ ] out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are feeling invulnerable
[Applause]
right to the balls [ __ ] just
dt all the way
it's vulnerable jeff garland had that up
his ass about an hour ago
god damn it
speaking of sights and sounds tonight
gabby will be doing those for this
evening thank you gabby so much we
appreciate it
josh not available tonight so he is out
where's dr joshua i don't know he's
fired i don't care where he is anymore
no i'm loyal he had a family thing he
had to go to so did he yeah we kind of
changed dates up on him because of the
oh
but that's right
this was supposed to happen when last
may what happened last month may 28th i
believe um how does it feel back there
gabs
good all right she's good
somebody said she left
starting with dan ruiz from riverside
california dan right up front i like
that t-shirt son well done my face is
looking back at me yes for those uh
listening at home uh dan's wearing a
gigantic ralph face t-shirt which makes
me feel very left out
it's like a shirt that screams i like
one of you very much
smith club guy right next i saw that
that's amazing thank you my friend he is
wearing it that kevin club so is kevin
on the back of that ralph shirt at least
no i think that's a ralph report shirt i
believe it's just all ralph yeah why
don't you have your conversation with
your little [ __ ] friend
dan asks if followers of the ralph
report are called the garmi
are followers of hollywood babylon
called hollywood babylonians or just
babylonians
i don't think we've ever even named the
folks who've listened to this show
i mean
you have
many times
how so you've called them irritating no
i haven't
i think babblers i think babblers is
better
uh babbliebers
[Laughter]
you know what it is [ __ ] funny
if you're gonna have a nickname for your
little monsters bad bleepers
at least it's kind of on brand they're
like jesus even in their name for their
fans they [ __ ] with justin bieber yes
exactly
uh thank you so much for being here dan
thanks for wearing that shirt too it's
making me hard what
[Laughter]
what's your name that kevin smith club
shirtware
jesse well thank you for being here
jesse
ralph and i both have patreon
uh olivia and chuck are you guys here
olivia and chuck oh i win
it's so tiny
a long time fan super excited to see you
guys my fiance chuck and i are selling
celebrating the fact that we finally set
a date for our wedding
after seven and a half years together
and four years engaged we decided what
the [ __ ] let's do this
that's the way you want to go into a
marriage by the way
what the [ __ ] i've invested this much
time
you've already had a marriage this is
going to be your second marriage
what
11 years is a [ __ ] marriage for a lot
of people love you yeah i don't think
it's that [ __ ] far so [ __ ] you're
saying i was getting married again i'm a
[ __ ] myself
[Laughter]
well that's the gist of this is they're
going to ask us for some marriage advice
it's like
never mind
four months to plan our wedding at an
italian banquet hall in an industrial
park in the suburbs of chicago
wow you guys are going all out that
sounds great
may not be a dream wedding but it's more
important that our family and friends
can all be there no it's really not
it's about food and booze really
we could use some encouragement and some
marriage advice what to do and what not
to do from you and kevin anal
is that a what to do or what not to do
let them figure it out
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't tell what people what to do i
just tell them what can be done i say
you give the potential that's right
that's right i'm progressive uh my
marriage didn't work out so i would i
would feel ill advised to give you any
uh
[Laughter]
any advice at all other than don't
chuck do you feel like buying her a
house at some point
besides the one you're going to live in
together
that's how it all goes just letting you
know
the wonder
at some point you're buying two houses
chuck that's all i'm saying i don't know
or chuck uh you could just do it this
way uh everything your wife does is
right
everything yeah
happy wife happy life john
unhappy wife you're buying a second
house yes that's right
uh sam and corey are you guys here wow
look at the front what's up kids and
yeah there's a [ __ ] jay and salam bob
okay you win the t-shirt competition
so far i'm winning the t-shirt war
uh my name is sam my friend corey and i
drove all the way from northern
california the san francisco bay area to
be at the show tonight [ __ ] man
that's [ __ ] nuts
you're unemployed
there's better places to spend your
money than on us i'll tell you that much
and the way gas is you could have flown
probably for cheaper when you're driving
wait wait wait you're saying it's nuts
that came from san francisco [ __ ]
claire flew 27 hours to go to the show
what is she insane claire
[Applause]
he's still awake claire fell asleep 10
minutes
uh sam and corey asked if it's not too
much trouble can sylvester stallone sing
the beatles classic obla-dio blada
[Applause]
it is an awful lot of trouble quite
frankly but uh but since you guys came
so far it's the least i could do gabby
can i get a little music for that please
[Music]
yeah
desmond has a marrow in the market oh no
wait i'll start now desmond has a barrel
in the market place
molly she's like a singer in the band
all right
says to molly hey i like your face
and molly says as she takes him by the
hand
over the d over the dot life goes on
bruh
let
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go
[Applause]
like your face
[Applause]
your face looks good you know
i was shooting half of that and i
realized i hadn't pressed record
but i was there for the course that's
their first that's the best part that's
all that matters
and uh lastly brandon rohrabacher are
you in the house brandon where are you
brandon hey there brandon's the official
historian of the ralph report if you
know that or not the official historian
yes he is yes how
he has an encyclopedic mind when it
comes to stuff that's happened on that
show for something is that right yes
he's the rain man of the ralph report
yeah yeah
definitely one hit wonder wednesday yeah
definitely yeah uh oh uh oh played that
one already oh may 15. may 15th 2020 uh
oh
couldn't do without him thank you
i hope kevin is feeling better he is he
got some mess uh
unintentionally but yes i'll be
attending the show with my friends will
and shauna we'll be celebrating will's
birthday could david bowie please wish
him a very happy birthday
of course i can uh will
where's will where is it hey will happy
birthday will let's get a little david
bowie going
[Music]
happy birthday to you william
happy birthday to you william
it's your special birthday william
and you're
celebrating it flappers
happy birthday to you william
we're so happy that you have joined us
happy birthday to you william
it's your special special but hey hey
hey
what's your hair what's your hair
so sexy
so sexy you can tell i haven't done it
in a while i went so fast on that one
yeah
next time will be a lot longer longer
lasting
yes
[Laughter]
it's covered long covered is what it is
we also get emails from all around the
world gaps
give me a little pause tonight i think
before some of those
[Music]
feels featuring kevin's reaction that's
right
uh first up is mike from berkshire
county massachusetts [ __ ]
[Laughter]
love the show love the yoga hosers he
writes what a good person
full of good taste we found him we found
that one guy i told you there was a guy
who liked it i knew somebody bought it
yeah
i especially loved ralph's introduction
when he was eating cereal with wagner
playing in the background that was
pretty funny it was yeah i don't care
what people say about that movie i love
that movie and it's aging better i mean
i'm not believe me i'm not deluding
myself but i have been through a career
where mall rats supposedly killed my
career and stuff and then 10 years later
people were like that movie's good my
favorite jersey girl supposed to kill my
career 10 years later people like that
movie's lovely yoga house is going to
take a few more years but
it's going to age like not fine wine but
like smelly cheese
but somebody like a boxed wine that you
can drink like a nice pink chablis yes
they'll get you drunk
white zin
uh mike asks the musical question what
would it sound like if arnold
schwarzenegger sang todd rundgren's
banged the drum all day
well there's only one way for us to
answer that question i suppose gabby
[Music]
play the camera i love it i
don't want to work i just want the bang
on the drum all day
i don't want to play
i just want to bang on the drum all day
right
ever since i was a tiny boy in austria i
don't want no candy i don't need a toy
all i needed was a stick and an empty
coffee can and then i banged on that
thing like it was my maid
i don't want to work
[Applause]
i just want to bang on the drum all day
yeah there we go that's enough of that
[Applause]
oh this next one this next one comes
from stephen detherage if that's his
name sounds a little terrifying sounds
like a book i was forced to read in
junior year
the tale of stephen detherage yeah
we haven't done this in a long time if
you're a long time listener of hollywood
babylon you may remember that kevin
identified
anne heish in the movie psycho
[Laughter]
as being one of the few high-profile
a-list buttholes you ever see in a major
motion picture i do feel like it was a
major discovery and uh like a few years
from now they won't talk about clerks
anymore but they will talk about this
yes the fact that i was the first one to
point out that if you look real closely
in the psycho remake from guys gus
fonson when anne hage gets killed in the
shower not an ish but her character
um she goes forward and dies and you can
see her [ __ ] yeah
and i maintain it's one of the few if
only times in cinematic history that you
could actually you've seen a lot of ass
but you never see the [ __ ] ring piece
ever ever and that i was always so blown
away by this when we started doing the
show over [ __ ] 10 years ago yeah it
became a point of conversation more than
that it gave us this this song remember
this song yes
that's right
it's the beloved children's program and
asia's
and so from time to time ever since
people will try to challenge the
butthole judge
and send in some footage from a movie to
see if this counts it hasn't happened in
so long i know
uh steven sent this in it's from the
movie body double
melanie griffith
and brian de palma directed 1984 yeah
craig watson yes i love this movie i do
too i love this film really really well
done flick god i forgot about
i haven't thought about it in years i
haven't either
it's a good switcheroo and it has a
really like sad ending like uh
so he's sending some footage he wants
you to take a look at and look at
melanie griffith's butthole and see if
it's actually shown in this film or not
you don't have to ask me to look at
melanie griffin's butthole twice all
right can we can we throw up the footage
up on the screens there gabby
it's a crisp
picture see he's looking at a tv screen
so it's kind of hard to tell
all right it's coming up in fact he does
us a favor actually freeze frames it for
us so holy [ __ ]
let's get a steel store though i think
we have a picture i think we've zoomed
in i think we've got a uh yeah oh that's
a little grainy but
i don't know it's your call you're the
you're the pro i'm not even gonna take
i'm not even gonna i'm not gonna touch
this one it's a video artifact that's
not ring piece it's not uh-uh not at
that point it's shadow and this was shot
in the 80s right so there was they
weren't doing like uh brazilians and
landing strips and virgin smoothies oh
you think it's far station things tended
to be hairier though
so i don't think in the 80s you wouldn't
even accidentally seen a butthole
because you'd have to get through the
roughage get there
so no fair enough all right the judge
has spoken no butthole
n.a still the winner man and he's still
the queen of buttholes
i believe so just for major motion
picture releases there are many fine
adult films where you can see buttholes
on this parade colon yeah
prolapsed [ __ ] yeah
this is just hollywood movies yes
although to be fair you can see [ __ ]
in a lot of [ __ ] hollywood that's
true just not sphincters
uh we also get folks who send in emails
from time to time of towns they live
near or run across that have [ __ ] up
names and we never got around to naming
this so we call it your town's got a
[ __ ] up name
[Music]
it comes from adam in grafton new
hampshire
love the show i live in grafton our town
just had two historical plaques
installed one marks the spot of an old
village which well had a pretty [ __ ]
up name as soon as i saw it i thought of
you and took this picture so we sent it
in this is the old village where grafton
used to stand
it is
folks also send us warnings more than
anything else we uh look at these things
that are meant for kids the kids are
supposed to enjoy this stuff uh toys and
whatnot they're meant for children to
enjoy but we look at them and go no
those are inappropriate
[Music]
[ __ ] is that toys
toys
uh chuck smith from coming georgia my
cousin
yes that's actually the city i live in
he writes coming george it's about
c-u-m-m-i-n-g
my name is chuck i ran across this
random video and applies to both
categories on the show it's beer for
kids
non-alcoholic beer for kids
why
here's from the uh here's from the
catalog where you can order it from
apparently it comes from japan we've got
a picture of that page
it says it's derived from fruit juice
caramel color and malt extract this
kid's beer works perfect as a fake beer
to help your kids feel included in
family events
that's when i in the 70s man when all my
relatives are drunk i really felt
exclusive did you feel like you're
outside why won't they hand me a [ __ ]
pabst why can't i get loaded and start
an argument
with my aunt and demand for the car keys
because i'm [ __ ] leaving
oh my god it's like you were there
that was my family too that was my
childhood just watching adults yell at
each other
if they would just stop drinking
it's all good and fun about until about
halfway into the party and then someone
was getting a lit cigarette flicked at
him
that's usually how the parties ended at
my house
so is that what that wasn't bad enough
there's some [ __ ] on the interwebs
who uh had his kid try it oh [ __ ] so
here's a little girl trying the fake
beer for the first time
it's child abuse
here's the taste test
[Music]
yeah she's like five
yeah
frothy head on it it is
looks like beer and the beer is big too
stop
not bad
[Laughter]
all right the less said about this part
of the video the better i think is that
how one drinks beer
well when one drinks something
so you're thinking what could be worse
than having kids drink fake beer that we
don't need to indoctrinate them it's
grooming is what it is
drinking beer that age true only worst
thing i could think of as a meth lab
across the street
or is it this new candy that michael
mcbride found he said i know you have no
love for poop related toys but how do
you feel about this this is a new
drinkable candy for kids oh that's so
[ __ ] up
sour liquid candy samples of urine for
the kids to enjoy
drinking urine out of a specimen jar
for children
i mean i know like kids like creepy [ __ ]
but ew
that would just be that's that's a
little too misleading that's too
misleading yeah
you'd be like this they're disappointed
yeah like
you're this tastes like candy this is
misleading
mom where's my urine you promised me
this don't pass the piss piss this john
cena's urine
and here's how they sell it by the way
in your local candy stores if you want
to look for it it comes in a uh
a urinal that's where you can pick it up
in a urinal
i bet you it sounds like crazy i'm sure
it does because we're over as a society
and lastly geekpool writes in i live in
canada i was driving by my old school
and saw they put a new slide at the
playground in the park across the street
i don't know about you but it looks
inappropriate to me here's apparently a
new slide on the playground oh [ __ ]
just a reminder to the kids how they got
there jesus
and you're going the wrong way by the
way if you're going down the slide it's
like a retrograde orgasm
it's like a very short man [ __ ] a
very tall woman yes
we're doomed can we put that back up for
a second
you're not done
it's hot in so many ways it's not hot in
the least
and again may i remind you it's for
children to play on
it could be like all right but put it in
like [ __ ] the you know the playboy
mansion then it changes its tune all
completely that's going into the grotto
pool and [ __ ] yeah make it a little hard
because if that didn't i can't okay
speaking of stiffs
we also paid
nicely done thank you artful
we also pay tribute to folks in show
business who passed away this week and
uh we look at their they're all too
short lives but they're long legacies
they leave behind in a segment called
the tinseltown stiffs
now another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed jim seals singer for
half of the giant duo of seals and crops
summer breeze made me feel fine
is that what it is what is it blowing
with the jasmine in my mind
the jasmine in my mind yeah
i like my version better
which if i'm not mistaken was i don't
know
seals and cropped in the 70s and early
80s monster duo they had a bunch of hits
in the top ten here's a little a little
medley if you will of some of their
biggest hits oh my
[Music]
me feel god
in my mind
[Music]
closer to you
get closer to me
[Music]
and jim seals won't pass this way again
no no that's a bummer oh i killed him
those cats own the 70s man they own my
childhood every one of those songs takes
me to a very specific moment [ __ ]
yacht rock heaven right there really
beautiful stuff don't you sometimes just
want a club that kevin smith well how
about instead you joined that kevin
smith club there are so many ways into
that kevin smith club ladies and
gentlemen you don't have to come through
the front door you can come through the
back door we like it that way sign up as
a clerk where you get access to all the
audio that we got or join as a mall rep
that gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join as a fun employee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that kevin smith
club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that kevin smith wake and bake
bowl for 2022 we've added some levels
including the fashionable mail you get
everything that the clerk the mall rat
the yoga hoser and the fun employee gets
but you also get once a year an
exclusive piece of wardrobe from a kevin
smith film or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rat the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house i
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bake and it
goes up on smodcast join us at
thatkevinsmithclub.com be a clerk be a
mall rap be a fun employee be a yogas or
be a fashionable male be a ranger danger
or be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
i'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that kevin smith club
um
things happen in movies and tv shows all
the time that someone should catch at
some point these are big budget
productions they should check it and fix
it but they don't because they hate us
that's why we call this segment [ __ ]
that should not be
[Music]
here's some [ __ ] that should not be
dave davidson from the uk writes in he
says
no i'm good thank you
drink urine
[Laughter]
uh showing this beloved favorite from my
childhood to my kid this week and i
noticed something that really shouldn't
have gone through it's not like this
fuck-up is in the background the whole
point of this scene is what happens in
the mirror so who wasn't paying
attention
it's from the uh famous kids richard
donner film the goonies oh sure yeah
goonies never die no well they [ __ ] up i
know that
yeah they did that a lot in this in this
movie uh here is uh robert davie
remember as one of the fratelli's yeah
who comes the world sings all the time
yes that's the key to the [ __ ] up in
this clip we're about to see right now
[Music]
you're gonna see this clip now look
mister i need a ride my friends and i
just had to run with these really
disgusting people you might have heard
of them the fratellis well we found our
hideout could you please please take me
to the sheriff's station i can describe
all three of them
leave your eyes on the mirror
[Applause]
he's a [ __ ] ventriloquist
singing with a cigarette in his mouth
i saw what the editor did there too it
was just like there's only three frames
where you could tell that he's not
singing at all and they were like who's
ever gonna see him yeah
us that's who when they made that movie
there was no freeze frame digital
technology and stuff so they didn't care
enough to make it right that's what
you're saying that's true but while
we're here though how [ __ ] awesome is
that kid's performance amazing spitting
out that [ __ ] line and [ __ ] whatever
happened to him
i think he's a lawyer or something like
that whenever you read those articles
about like where are they now because
they've done them every few years but
there's always when dick donner was
still alive there was always this kind
of looming
promise that they would sequel go back
again and in this era where everything
gets called back or gets a [ __ ]
sequel or
you know whether they keep trying to you
know uh monetize our sentimentality and
whatnot
how the [ __ ] have they not done the
goonies that's true how do you only do
that [ __ ] thing once maybe that's
what makes it so beautiful is that
they've never [ __ ] touched it and
generations have enjoyed it in that
version yeah over and over and over or
do they i wonder if like a modern day
kid could still enjoy the group i think
so without being like where's the ipad
can't they just [ __ ] google this why
don't they just get maps or waze and
they can find their way to the treasure
well they're carrying a map
you have arrived at one-eyed willies
this avoids a
accident on the 405.
we also look at acting
even a-list actors sometimes turn in
less than great performances they can't
always be great but we have found
sometimes the worse they get the more it
goes all the way around to become
exquisite acting
to be
or not to be
that is the question
welcome to the world of exquisite acting
with ralph garman and kevin smith
um harrison ford not knowing for being
the most energetic performer no show us
[Laughter]
which is going to be the next indiana
jones
that's a verbatim scene from that pretty
much oh my god
a lot of that but in this scene from a
film called hollywood homicide oh i
remember this but uh what's his name
josh josh
hartnett oh yeah yeah he was gonna be
something for a minute really what yeah
this time
yeah he wasn't a thing with that uh
harrison ford is in the midst of a uh
pearl harbor that's right yeah uh
harrison ford's in the midst of a chase
trying to bring down the bad guys and
he's trying to commandeer vehicles for
some reason he gets very angry at a
little girl on her bicycle
here's the exquisite acting
hey get out of the car please please get
out hey hey look come on
[Laughter]
he's the one stealing the bike
he's experiencing white rage
oh jeez
[ __ ] man you know i see him scream at
the big black guy by the way
door
he was like
little girl gets picked on
we like to take a look at all the
entertainment news each week as well in
a little segment we call the hbo
headlines
[Music]
duke nukem is finally gonna be a movie
oh [ __ ] my life is complete well i know
you're not a big gamer but for folks who
like especially first person shooter
games duke nukem was like the granddaddy
yeah he was the one to be bfg right yeah
they have announced that they're finally
going to make the movie i wouldn't
ordinarily be excited about this because
i'm not a gamer either and i ever played
this in the 90s when it was wildly
popular but the guys behind
cobra kai geniuses are going to be
producing it and developing it i think
they've got the perfect tone and sense
of humor
what kind of show is just beautiful it's
so good what else are you watching
watching that's good right now yeah what
are the hacks you watch i haven't seen
that yet so [ __ ] good um i just
watched watching the offer you watching
the offer the making of the watch the
first part yeah moving on i uh
miss marvel have you watched it not yet
[ __ ] fantastic i've heard good things
so it's full of joy that girl is just
she's a star but the whole [ __ ] show
is absolutely wonderful um my only bone
of contention
they're in jersey yes there's a
convenience store oh no oh no
you don't [ __ ] reach out yeah okay
stuart king i mean there's time still i
guess yeah no it's a beautiful [ __ ]
chair are your lawyers involved yeah
like you'll be hearing from my life um
they uh i also watch are you up on obi
wan yes
[ __ ] fantastic it's a lot of fun if
you'd [ __ ] told me as a kid like one
day you're gonna get a flat-out darth
vader show yeah we're just [ __ ] like
he's so petty and shitty that he drags
one guy through the fire to be like
that's what you did to me yeah you piece
of [ __ ]
oh i couldn't believe it man i was like
this is where we are like i
i love the star wars movies don't get me
wrong but like star wars works insanely
well as episodic television yeah and
it's been a joy i know there are some
people that like [ __ ] about the nice
things but like i've enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of it some of it is jarring to me in
terms of what it means from the original
films that i watched i'm like oh i did
bump into it takes me out of the moment
a little bit because i'm busy trying to
figure out the logic behind it you know
but ewan mcgregor is just such a
pleasure to watch he's charming the
kid's charming [ __ ] like the whole
thing is just like i when they announced
obi-wan i was like i give a [ __ ] and
then you know i was like you want to
impress me give me alec guinness obi-wan
yeah and i'll [ __ ] be impressed this
has actually been pretty [ __ ]
wonderful man so far is hayden
christensen in the show yeah he plays
darth vader he's the guy he walks around
in the suit and he's awesome how
desperate is he for work
there he should get they're gonna give i
bet you they give him a whole show out
of this because he does now where he
doesn't deliver any dialogue again yeah
he wears a suit no he gets to flashback
and [ __ ] like that you see his forehead
once
i mean somebody you know who was a david
brown's played darth vader yeah david
perez didn't star in a movie before that
take it i'm just wondering i heard he's
coming back as anakin skywalker's like
well this guy's career wow they're good
for him he's finally getting a second
bite at the apple and then he's like
yes you have done that too i'm like
that's not that guy at all
they got james yeah i know that's the
guy he's gonna be anybody in that
[ __ ] suit you don't know
i mean
hayden could be back at the arby's
working his regular [ __ ]
he's just picking up the check
you know no one is a [ __ ] great actor
you know what i don't like about
sandwiches is because there's the word
sand in them
oh
i don't like scents sound gets
everywhere just like the sandwiches dude
can i just have my order please
got two kids waiting in the car more
horsey sauce
i'm sorry but the sandwiches get
everywhere
oh my god the guy's enjoying the moment
you gotta [ __ ] on it
he's gonna find you and drag you to fire
right on your james earl jones will
that's who'll do it
oh god uh speaking of villains nick
cannon's having another baby
he's he's very good at that yeah he is
well being his ninth child is on the way
you know man like five different women i
think where did it say be fruitful and
prosper is that the bible uh yes yes be
fruitful and multiply it multiply yes
kids live in a biblical life yeah yes
yeah he says someone should take his
calculator away because he's multiplying
way too [ __ ] much
he needs to be uh he should be fixed
because he doesn't it doesn't end up
with any of these women he doesn't have
a family relationship with most of these
kids but i mean you know [ __ ] thank
you uh those are social mores like you
know we're animals it wouldn't
necessarily if we didn't have a society
or civilization we wouldn't necessarily
wind up with the same people for life
that whole notion of like we're together
for life and we love each other that's
like that's only about maybe what a
couple hundred years old and that came
from what the troubadours this came from
art the whole notion that we should that
we should fall deeply in love eternally
in love and [ __ ] like that came from a
bunch of artisans singers who go around
singing these songs of undying love and
[ __ ] like that prior to that people got
married for dowries and for we can
secure land and [ __ ] like that to stop
wars right these [ __ ] singers were
like i'm gonna love you forever and [ __ ]
people are like that's beautiful is that
the way it should be and it literally
[ __ ] changed the world and now we all
believe in this notion of like [ __ ]
eternal love and there's only one person
out there for me and [ __ ] nick cannon
understands man so you're saying nick
cannon's breaking down he really is the
facade of society spread that seed
around and keep the species going he's
just not into raw dogging and then
walking away is what you're saying yes
he's being yeah i'm sure well the nine
kids when they're in therapy will find
that very comforting
oh my dad didn't abandon me he was just
breaking down social mores okay
i'm good now i'm gonna put down the pipe
[Music]
did you say social mores i think i did
like more eels
i believe it's more so pronounced
maurice i think it's moore's i don't
think so
oh let's hear from applause how many
people think it's maurice
how many people think it's moors
i think we're all equally as dumb yeah
sounded about balance right there
claire
claire you're british you'll know is it
more rays or mores
in the uk
you have more than you can that's like
othello and [ __ ] that's a different kind
of more no that's like [ __ ] stay on
the path stay off the moors
otherwise get bit by the american
werewolf in london
well a lot of people think stuff we're
looking for someone to find that
definition i think more is an eel and i
think moore's
i believe that's spelled differently i'm
sure it is but i think there are common
homonyms more rays
[Applause]
wow
the voice of god it really was and the
voice of god was like google that was
nuts
more rays
morons
there we go i stand corrected
oh this is good news food i like it we
learned some [ __ ] tonight yeah it's
education useful information right there
uh this is nice news the foo fighters
the surviving foo fighters are gathering
together for two tribute shows for their
fallen band mate taylor hawkins
he's very cool they seemed very very
close you're familiar with dave dave's a
friend yeah and uh he was destroyed by
uh taylor's name seems so in the public
yes very much in the press
and uh i knew taylor just very casually
but he was such a wonderfully kind
charming guy it was really sad news to
hear when they seem like super tight
like they're a family of those guys yeah
and uh
they did no one knew what the future of
the band would be quite frankly when
taylor left and we still don't but we do
know they will be paying tribute to him
at two different shows one at london's
wembley stadium on september
and another one september 27th here in
los angeles at the kia forum known as
the
uh great western forum down there in
englewood
where the
lakers used to play yeah yeah well i was
gonna say where the kings used to play
but yeah oh yeah them too yeah so uh
fabulous forum yes that's now the what
the kia the kia forum interesting yeah
so tickets go on sale i want to say will
he drop her
no but i mean he's the drummer so
oh dave girl you mean
yes bro
well taylor was the drummer of that band
no [ __ ] so that's why we were talking
about everyone was a little surprised no
we were talking about dave so i was like
will dave trump will not guess he'll be
up front i'm sure with his guitar and
he'll be singing because during the
shows he would go back and drama let
taylor come up front and sing clearly he
can do it yeah occasionally but i
believe they'll probably bring in guest
drummers i'm guessing and i hope they
bring back that girl from the uh
uh what's your name mandy yes i believe
it was yeah the viral video oh my god
all those [ __ ] videos are so badass
and that kid drums with such joy and
enthusiasm yeah i hope she's gonna be
huge forever oh that'd be amazing
i hope they do that i do too yeah
madonna is making her own biopic
what could go wrong
what do you mean she's
producing it oh oh no more than that
she's directing oh oh more than that
she's writing it as well kevin she's
writing producing and directing her own
bio pic i mean good for her it's her
life
kevin what
what kind of film do you think you're
going to get from a narcissist who
thinks everything they do is art what
kind of story are they going to tell
about themselves clerks
[Laughter]
point taken yeah point
just saying there are precedents
um good for her man instead of like
letting somebody else do and then being
like pissed off about it later on like
oh they didn't get it right she can't be
mad if they don't get it right like
she's gonna tell her own life story
that's true a little girl from ozark can
play it yes julia garner has been cast
from ozark and inventing anna i think we
got a shot of the two of them side by
side it's pretty like i wouldn't have
you know i've seen her in many things
and she's wonderful on that inventing
anna and stuff but i never would have
put that together until they did the
side by side i was like i could totally
see that yeah totally with enough makeup
and stuff you can actually make that
happen and and in a world where remember
pam and tommy the [ __ ] hulu series
how they made the actress look like like
uh pamela anderson yeah there's no way
they don't get close can't believe
madonna didn't demand to play herself in
the movie that's the only thing that's
the only part of it i can't understand i
mean don't rule out that she'll be in it
at some point oh yeah for sure
i i didn't know that she was directing
it yeah that's interesting yeah it is
you're so nice
that's why you have me sitting next to
you i'm your hatchet i know you're there
and yet you thought i was saying like i
didn't i did not know where that was
coming from at all i just misunderstood
not at all
uh sad news
ted lasso was going to end after its
third season no
why because that was the original plan
they were always going to do three and
they're going to stick to it well i had
original plans that i [ __ ] changed
when i got married so they could [ __ ]
change brett goldstein who of course
plays uh oh what's his name dude roy
[Music]
uh he's also one of the writers on the
show and he said they all agreed to do
three seasons look it looks like they're
gonna stick to it i sat down with him in
england
during uh jane salam bob reboot before
this long before ted lasso happened he
has a podcast yeah
and it was one of my favorite interviews
i've ever done because it's got a theme
that you kind of stick in and [ __ ] it's
about dying and what you take with you
to the grave so i've never met him
before i just thought he was this like
insanely [ __ ] funny dry podcaster i
had a blast with him and then i'm
watching ted lasso and i was like
i swear to god that guy looks like the
dude i did a podcast with
i was like couldn't be and then a couple
of months later i saw a tweet with a
like because i was like i [ __ ] love
ted lasso and roy cat's amazing and
somebody was like you and him hung out
at england
and i was like i [ __ ] knew it it was
where i can
so uh yeah the whole cast is just
outstanding
absolutely we need more of that we need
more ted lasso in the world not less
[ __ ] agreed man but at the same time
if they're like look we're gonna give
you three of our best
and then get out it's a very british way
of doing television by the way it's not
a british show right it's an american
show yeah but a lot of people involved
in it are brits and they probably
respond to that kind of but a lot of
them having an having an end game early
on so you shoot for that a lot of people
who are watching are american
or yet another jurassic yeah it's just
like keep [ __ ] going
i haven't seen it i'm not saying it's
good or bad but it's like we are on the
what eighth no
sixth iteration of a jurassic park
kevin you're missing the point they
bring dinosaurs back
i don't think you get it it keeps
happening yes
i'm just waiting for like right now like
they started with jurassic park
and then they moved to like jurassic
world and stuff yes hopefully the next
three
are just humanless movies about
dinosaurs
that just fight each other or don't do
anything like that and then you watch
that and then make it 30 minutes instead
of two hours yes the brontosaurus
grazing that's all we want bro we just
want to see cool dinosaurs like that's
[ __ ] up oh that's [ __ ] up oh they're
fighting all right credits and then go
home and [ __ ]
that's it nobody cares about [ __ ]
chris pratt and [ __ ] you know price
and [ __ ] like just want to see dinosaurs
what if they evolve and they start
wearing like clothes and talking [ __ ]
it'd be amazing right they were like a
flintstones like family exactly yes
i'd watch that show me too
what happened
oh dinosaurs that's right henson right
did that show years ago yeah
oh well it's another idea we won't have
[Laughter]
you didn't get that information from him
you knew that right i completely forgot
about that show until now i never really
thought we were doing a bit no no
i was like i know that's
like a
forgot about that
but we're a comedy team i'm working solo
over here
hey guys
why don't you walk up here and
take the real ralph's place yeah
and uh let's just say that computer oh
yeah it's easy
speaking of dinosaurs well he's not one
yet but we can only hope justin bieber
is in the news this week yeah here's a
little bieber theme
[Music]
tell you why
cause you're a little [ __ ] yeah yes it's
a great week to pick to do justin bieber
news i gotta tell you
i've rarely been this happy
he had a rough week today
you better believe it
he's got ramsay hunt syndrome
i don't know who ramsay and or hunt are
but i would like to send them a bottle
of something as a thank you
oh shut up it's temporary it'll be fine
can i have my fun
what is it uh it's a form of uh the
herpes uh
virus like check out the herpes a
version of it like chicken pox they're
all part of the same board like the cold
source herpes simplex virus yes there's
a whole family of uh
herpes zoster viruses i believe they're
called and it's like shingles and
chicken pox and
oh yes shingles is in that family oral
herpes and genital herpes there's a
whole bunch of them so hot this this is
this is one of those it's a rare disease
called the ramsey hunt syndrome and he's
had to cancel a bunch of shows so
there's an upside
to this
how does it manifest uh it affected the
nerves
because that's how they that's how the
virus travels in most of these different
versions it afflicts the nerves it
afflicted the nerves on one side of his
face and one side of his face is
temporarily paralyzed so like my father
at one point he had bell's palsy is it
like that i believe that's also
kind of like like half of his face
seemed to go to sleep for a couple
months yeah that's what this is like for
bieber so um understandably he
immediately took to social media and did
a close-up video of himself talking to
everybody with his paralyzed face and
i'd like to think it was just a gift for
me quite frankly
i don't know if he knows me or not but
here's a little bit of justin talking
about what he's going through i hope you
enjoy this as much as i do
as you can see this eye is not blinking
i can't smile on this side of my face
this nostril will not move oh
so there's full paralysis in this side
of my face
so for those who are frustrated by my
cancellations of the next shows um
i'm just physically obviously not
capable of doing them
uh this is pretty serious as you can see
um i wish this wasn't the case
but obviously my body's telling me i got
to slow down
he's still as sharp as articulate as
ever he's still got that going for him
that is so the one delay of the blink is
a little unnerving but other than that
like it's not that bad if he just talked
and didn't show what he can't do like i
wouldn't have known that does not look
like what my father looked like no
bell's palsy is much more severe and
usually along get longer lasting so this
apparently will resolve temporarily but
all kidding aside he is a you know he's
a person and he's sick and so it's not
right to take a shot so please don't
laugh at this photo
ever again please
please don't look at that and laugh your
[ __ ] asses off oh my god
it's [ __ ] hilarious i know but let's
all please give the man his dignity and
not
[ __ ] piss ourselves laughing laughing
at
him looking like a pirate
hey man he am what he am
[Laughter]
we always like to take a look at all the
geek news in the world hit us cabs
[Music]
spider-man no way home didn't make
enough money so they're gonna re-release
it
with additional footage oh [ __ ] really
yeah this is a good idea if they could
put more [ __ ] in it yeah it's spider-man
no way home the more fun stuff version
so it's gonna be longer yes
they're not cutting anything out and
thicker apparently really yeah
that's why it's more fun yeah no doubt
right you're going to feel it this time
yes
us and canada begin september 2nd
they're going to re-release it as a part
of the honoring of the 30th anniversary
of spider-man's first appearance in
comic books amazing fantasy of 14. yes
as well as a celebration of two decades
of spider-man movies that sony has
released i mean look i
i the less i say about that spider-man
movie the better the last time i
said something i made a [ __ ] comment
where i was like you know
this spider-man movie could have been
the one one of the 10 movies
nominated oh i remember the best picture
and i got [ __ ] crucified on the
internet people were like you should
have died from the heart attack
because of that and then sam jackson two
days later was like i think spider-man
should have been nominated for an oscar
and the internet was like you're right
sam tell him
i got no juice
here's the uh teaser that they released
this week from sony with all three
spider-man letting us know what's gonna
happen
hey i'm spider-man i'm spider-man i'm
spider-man
this is so cool we should do this again
you got it
come on that's so cute
[Applause]
i i would actually go back and see that
i would too even though i own it
digitally i would totally go i would go
see more fun stuff
speaking of fun stuff they're making
another joker movie with joaquin phoenix
that should be a good time at the
theaters
todd phillips revealed they are uh
currently looking at the new script
called joker
foley ado
[Music]
um that first one was pretty
wonderful pretty like [ __ ] serious
filmmaking right there i've uh still yet
to see it you've never seen that
it's it's i'm telling you every time i
approach it i go i'm not in the mood for
that i know i just can't and i've backed
off you'd be surprised you get into like
about
you can't 15 minutes in the movie is
tough to deny even if you go in with an
attitude it's like it's not it's not
attitude it's just i i i i can't deal
with a lot of grim these days for some
reason and i'm afraid it might be too
grim for me at this moment it is so i've
been keeping the arm's length quite
frankly it's it is pretty grim but
wonderfully made man very very uh
scorsese scorsese was clearly that's the
influence right yeah um apparently so
just like the way remember how like
quentin did
in glorious bastards and you're like
holy [ __ ] why didn't anyone kill hitler
in a movie before like what a good
[ __ ] idea this guy like took material
that everybody kind of knows and just
remixed it in the way we're like oh [ __ ]
like he made him the hero of the story
right now
this is pretty pretty ingenious the
second film's title is a french phrase
which means a shared madness
so they're wondering if perhaps someone
else another character will join him for
the second film i hope it'd be willem
dafoe
uh guardians of the galaxy three has
announced that maria bakalova has joined
the cast she was borat's daughter in the
second floor she was great brilliant
didn't she get nominated for uh i think
she didn't nominate at least the golden
globe if not an oscar bless you hey keep
that [ __ ] over there yeah he's already
uh you're invulnerable what are you
doing
here
uh james gunn recently teased the
involvement of unannounced actor in the
cast and he said that was the one he was
keeping a secret still no word on the
character she's going to play but this
cast is just getting
exponentially larger and more impressive
because we wouldn't want to work with
james comey yeah he's talented he's like
a good guy yeah yeah
uh the boys has been renewed for season
four and amazon amen now we're talking i
have not watched the first few episodes
of season three i'm holding them i had a
bunch oh you haven't seen them yet okay
we won't spoil them for you you're gonna
change you're gonna have a good job
jason muse just caught up to the show he
hasn't watched it until now so he
watched season one season two and i'm
jealous of all the great episodes and he
was like i can't do this he's like i
can't how did you do this watch it one
episode a week what the [ __ ] is that all
about i was like oh we did this as kids
and he's like i'm not a child anymore
i want all of it and i'm like well it's
coming it's coming so he first said i'm
not a child and then said i want what i
want but i want it yes i see okay that
makes sense
and dc has revealed their black adam
trailer this week the rock starring as
anti-hero black adam traditionally a
villain to uh
right
i guess while lemon seed
what happens in that instance lemon tree
grows in your stomach everyone knows
that
uh
everyone
don't do that to a guy who's high
good point
claire google that
well in england we have never seen
i believe we just call them lemon seeds
she can't be bothered to google sisters
[ __ ] flew 27 hours to see your ass
and you just mocked her and [ __ ]
uh black adam villain of shazam
traditionally although not in this
particular yeah shazam's bad guy yeah so
now the lead in his own movie and then
sort of anti-hero yeah he gets brought
into the justice society with dr fate
and adam smasher and cyclone and becomes
a good guy
qualified as you'll find out in the
trailer here is the trailer to black
adam opening in theaters october 21st
[Music]
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
[Music]
wherever i go
they're villains
heroes don't kill people
well i do
my vision has shown me the future
you have two choices
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
[Music]
he's been very uh passionate about
making that movie for like a decade at
this point yeah happy for him all right
i like pierce brosnan in that too is dr
phoebe that's the thing i'm most excited
about dr fate one of my favorite dc
characters yeah i think everyone is the
perfect casting is kent nelson he just
sounds yes
yeah going pierce brosnan yes
you [ __ ] are you working on a tenth
impression
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes
yes kevin
say
remington well he's older now so his
voice is deeper so he's
yes so he does but he was younger he's
like yes oh miss holt oh yes brendan
steele
miss paul
yes
yes yes
and now he's older and he talks like
this we're doing when he was james bond
hmm yes money penny
[Laughter]
yes specter yes
[Laughter]
yes
do you think they ever bring him back in
a bond movie no
you don't think there's one bomb movie
in the future where they're like we're
so desperate multi-verse
yes where it's all the bonds man
fighting each other every living bond
yes i'm back yes
the [ __ ] you are i'm back
that's what's impressive
look at me i'm a [ __ ] hologram
i'm all computer generated for [ __ ]
sake
that's what i would like to see
all right before we say goodnight boys
and girls we got one last bit of
business it turns out that uh liam
neeson's [ __ ] is the gift that keeps on
giving
for almost the entirety of the run of
this show we've been taking facts from
you the lovely members of uh of the
babbler badly of bloomers
the believers the believers
every week you send in your facts about
liam neeson's [ __ ] you can send those to
us at hbo podcast aol.com you can email
us about anything i know it's hilarious
now but
i'm way too [ __ ] lazy to change it so
it's not going anywhere
your folks send in your facts each week
and we recap some of our favorites it's
time for liam neeson's [ __ ]
[Music]
we should do another version of the show
like this is hollywood batman this is
hbo yes but then we do a double show and
that's hbo max
and then we get a letter of cease and
desist yes we do
damn a lot of time in court
liam neeson's got famously uh one of the
largest in show business [ __ ] huge
it's like a goddamn evian bottle it's
pretty big according to janice dickinson
one of his girlfriends she claimed it
was like a large evian yeah that was
quote right there that's very that
really gives you a picture it really
does yes
and so here's some more things to give
you a picture about liam neeson's [ __ ]
liam neeson's [ __ ] is so big
[Applause]
it's the only thing rising higher than
gas prices
oh [ __ ]
people felt that yeah it did it stings
at the beginning i know it's a joke i
don't like it
because it's kind of true
leonie's [ __ ] is so big
it's so big obi-wan is hiding in his
urethra to avoid detection from the
empire
only makes sense because he was his uh
his
nickname for his dick is the dune sea
that's right
liam neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it's so big johnny depp suited for 15
million dollars
[Laughter]
liam neese's [ __ ] is so big
it's so big rooster and maverick hit
nine g's attempting to fly over it
[Laughter]
and lastly liam neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it didn't catch monkey pox but it caught
king kong pox oh
[ __ ] ladies and gentlemen to burbank
have you had a good time this evening
thank you for joining us we truly
appreciate it if you enjoyed yourselves
because the man to my left give it up
for the one the only the legend ralph
[ __ ] garmin
let's hear it from my bestest battle
brother and buddy kevin smith
and that is hollywood babylon for this
week i'm kevin smith i'm ralph carman
battle the [ __ ] off good night
[Music]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask have anything every saga has a
10 year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sound bob get old i'm kevin smith